hey guys Pete here it's time for another
update on all the news that is leaking
out of the filming locations for Game of
Thrones season seven this week the show
started filming in Spain where they're
filming out me open as opposed to the
closed sets of Northern Ireland I must
stress the spoiler warning here this
video will contain mega spoilers for the
upcoming season if you don't want to
hear speculation about who is going
where and what is going to happen in
season 7 I suggest that you don't
continue my last video had a lot of
leaked stuff but Spain has provided a
lot more info including certain
important cast members filming their
scenes you've officially been warned so
let's jump right in it after my last
video some of you asked about Santa who
hadn't shown up in the photos from
Belfast yet this week she popped up on
set wearing her red wig for the first
time we didn't get a lot of surprising
info on what or who she was shooting
with but we did get some cool shots with
Kit Harington and Bella Ramsay who plays
Lyanna Mormont so the characters on the
set at the same time as her were Davos
Jon Snow Lyanna Mormont Brienne and
Podrick
no shockers there but still exciting
that things are moving Twitter user
yuk-ster also caught this photo at
London City Airport tobias plays admir
thali
so he was returning from Belfast when
this picture was taken this means that
he will probably see ed Muir in season 7
which opens up a lot to speculate about
do you think this means that ed Neiers
niece Arya might be paying him a visit
now that she's assassinated the phrase
who were holding him we can't know for
sure but I for one am glad that we'll
get to see some admin your next season
the last big sighting from Belfast was
Ellie Kendrick who plays Mirror read
this isn't that surprising since we
pretty much knew she would be in the
next season but where she was shooting
is exciting these photos were taking at
money glass which is the location that
is the home to the Winterfell set
Watchers on the wall reported that
unless Game of Thrones pulled a fast one
and started to use the same site for
other scenes after using it only for
Winterfell for a long time this would
mean that Meera is arriving at
Winterfell
obviously we're mirror goes we can
expect brand to go so this could mean
that bran is going home in the last
video I talked about how
bran would be shooting a scene with
dollars Edie at the wall but wasn't sure
if he would make it down to Winterfell
or not this isn't a full confirmation by
any means but it does seem more likely
now of course bringing a mirror could
get separated or something like that but
let's keep in mind that Mira's role on
the show is to travel with and keep an
eye on brand I hope we see the Starks
all together Winterfell so let's cross
our fingers the last little nugget from
northern island is a photo of an unknown
actor who could be playing an unknown
character if you guys have any ideas on
who this might be then let me know in
the comments now onto the mega spoilers
the stuff that has come out of northern
island has been interesting and pretty
normal as far as what you expect to see
during filming the stuff in Spain on the
other hand has been mind-blowing I must
give a lot of credit to the paparazzi
because honestly the the pictures we've
seen make it look as though you could
just walk like up and start watching
them film right there um so much info
has poured out of Spain this week that I
should stress again if you don't want
some of the major story points spoiled
for season 7 stop watching now these
guys have pretty much been filming the
crew filming the scenes since there's so
much I'll just start from the beginning
of the week and bring you up to present
because pretty much every day this week
has provided at least one crazy
revelation the first pictures we got
were of the crew setting up the
different filming locations and getting
things ready the crew arrived early to
prepare some of the rakia shorelines of
the Basque Country and on Tuesday the
cast started showing up on set last
video I talked about Dany treating with
Davos and Brienne which has been
speculated about but this time I can
tell you for certain that Davos and
Tyrion will be meeting on a beach a
local newspaper el correo posted a video
that shows the two characters having a
conversation near a small boat the clips
about four minutes long and we can
clearly see both characters in their
costumes Tyrion has a new black look
that is like what we saw the Narus
wearing when she made him her hand last
season and Davos well he's dressed like
Davos we can't really tell what they're
doing but it looks like Davos is getting
set to leave or maybe he just arrived in
the small boat the location of the
meeting is pretty significant as well
since the most likely place they're
shooting here is Dragonstone I'm going
to put out a separate video talking
about dragon students history later this
week but if you don't remember this is
where you know Stannis used to be
located it's also the ancestral home of
the Targaryen from the time they first
came to the west and it's where Daenerys
was born after the tearing and Davos
scene popped up things quieted down a
bit but lots of pictures started rolling
out on Twitter from Sameach and a place
I can't really pronounce so I won't try
that's in Burma oh this site is a small
islet connected to the mainland by this
cool-looking bridge it had been curious
that while filming was getting ready to
start that there hadn't been much
preparation but on the day before the
shooting was scheduled to start a local
news channel noticed that they added
these beacons along the bridge which is
pretty much all it needed to look like
something out of Game of Thrones on the
beach at zoom eya the crew was adding
stone structures to make it look more
like the other location and we got a
shot of them setting up to shoot around
a cave again all of this would indicate
that dragon stone is going to be where
something goes down but we're also going
to see an unrelated scene being shot at
these locations as well on the same day
actors like Kit Harington and Natalie
Emmanuel were spotted coming into town
at the very same time reports from Uriel
a beach where the Davao cinterion scene
was shot started rolling in los siete
Raynaud's reported that the morning
scene involved avos Tyrion and Gendry
the first scene had them landing on
shore but later in the day they shot a
separate scene that looked like it
involved gold cloaks later a video with
raw footage of the scene emerged to
provide a better idea of what was going
on
it appears that Davos and Gentry are
together preparing the boat to leave
when the two gold cloaks come up Davos
demonstrates that the boat is innocently
empty by pulling back the tarp he
appears then to bribe the gold cloaks or
give them or try to give them something
who and they turn to leave but just then
Tyrion walks out and things change the
gold cloaks see Tyrion and come back
perhaps they recognize him he is a
famous dwarf
a Lannister and then Davos tries to talk
to them again but the guards are
grabbing at their swords
that's when Gendry intervenes picks up
his Warhammer from the boat and starts
striking them down from behind then
Davos Tyrion and Gendry push the boat
off shore and get the hell out of Dodge
think about that for a second you know
who else used the Warhammer ginjuries
freakin dad King Robert Baratheon how
Gendry gets hooked back up with these
guys is beside the point
he is savaging gold cloaks with a war
ham also gold cloaks are from the city
watch of King's Landing so this part of
the beach isn't Dragonstone
instead it's probably on the shores of
Blackwater Bay which is where you would
probably land if you were coming to
King's Landing from Dragonstone later
some more news was confirmed about this
scene by lo siete Reynosa again
apparently Davos does not attempt to
bribe them with gold but with some crabs
that he promises are an aphrodisiac this
doesn't work so Gendry has to whack them
with his new Warhammer which we know is
marked by the house Baratheon stag sigil
if there was any doubt that Gendry had
forged it himself
well that would indicate that he has
furthermore l7r has learned that this
episode is the fifth of the season which
is only a few before the finale and that
it was directed by Matt Shak Minh if
this would have been the last news come
out of Spain I would have felt
pleasantly overwhelmed with all the
leakage but on the very next day el
correo dropped even bigger bombs from
the bridge where we saw they had
installed those beacons over the next
two days s bridge at what looks to be
Dragonstone had some very important
characters spotted on it first we got
some glimpses of the Dothraki with some
added fur to their outfits on the set
nearby and then we saw Mass and Eden
heiresses number one companion dressed
in a new geta after that we got this gem
with Jon Snow dressed like a king in the
north with Davos by his side this seems
to confirm that Jon is traveling south
to Daenerys his home base
if you aren't convinced check out the
Dothraki guarding the walkway in this
next photo Jon is confirmed to be
traveling with Davos somewhere that is
controlled by dinero
is Dothraki there just isn't a different
explanation for this as of all this
wasn't enough yesterday fans got what
they were hoping for a shot of Daenerys
with her entourage on the same bridge
emilia clarke had been spotted coming
into town the night the same night that
john and davos were seen shooting and
the next morning we got a photo of Dany
Tyrion grey worm Varys and Miss Andy all
on the bridge with her hand of the Queen
Tyrion at her side the mother of dragons
appears to be headed to treat with the
king in the north
Jon Snow later in that same shoot we got
images that include members of the
northern entourage John and Davos with
Musante and Terry Danny isn't pictured
in this scene but we can imagine if they
are going to meet to talk it would
probably happen inside of Dragonstone
anyways and that would be shot at their
Studios either way seeing these four
walking together is unreal and I can't
wait to see how this all goes down there
was one last bit of news that came out
today when I was writing this script
it's that Phillip O'Sullivan has joined
the cast this year / Watchers on the
wall his CV now reads that his last job
was playing a maester at the Citadel in
Game of Thrones season 7 there isn't
much more that we know but this is the
first we've heard about Sam's storyline
so let's hope you get more news about
that in the coming weeks so wow just a
ton of new stuff to speculate about plus
the crew is writing another beach
location for new filming that will be
starting this Monday coming up it's
almost hard to pick out what's most
exciting about out of this batch of
stuff I mean obviously Dany and Jon
coming together Dragonstone is huge but
just think about the different reunions
that are coming up for Tyrion he's been
gone from Westeros for some time and was
on opposite sides of the Battle of the
Blackwater against Davos in fact his
wildfire tactic wiped out Davos his
oldest sons and you know they have some
history also he was close with John when
he was at the wall so they haven't seen
each other in quite some time either I
don't think the new stuff really changes
much about what we've been talking about
over the last couple months one thing to
think about though is dragon stone has a
dragon pit as well as King's Landing so
there is a possibility that the early
rumors about Danny being at King's
Landing might have
and incorrect I don't know though if
Davos Brienne and Daenerys are supposed
to meet up at a dragon pit it's possible
that Danny and Davos are there together
meeting with Brienne if John came South
and Sansa was left to take care of
things in the north and it's possible
this would be a coming together of the
different factions in King's Landing
perhaps after Queen Cersei is removed
from the throne at this point there is
so much news swirling around it's hard
to keep it all straight even if we don't
know how things are going to play out we
have a lot to think about before Steven
season 7 gets started and we have Gendry
forging a Warhammer with the Baratheon
stag on it let me know what you guys
think in the comment to do another shout
out for a YouTube channel for charity
called trial by trivia I'll put a link
up top and in the in the description
it's a fun concept where you can go
watch a live stream where the guys and
girls ask questions and you can compete
against other Game of Thrones fans in
the trivia chat it's a lot of fun and
they also put together tournaments
pitting different YouTube creators
against each other they've asked me to
participate in the next tournament which
will be teams so hopefully whoever they
pair me up with will be able to carry my
ass because their questions are really
like episode specific and tough either
way you'll have the potential chance to
see me get embarrassed on a live stream
for charity it's a win-win really please
like this video if you want to see more
videos like it and leave me some
comments about your theories from all of
what's come out this week tin foil or
otherwise subscribe to my channel to
keep up with all the latest news and
leave a comment to be eligible for my
subscriber book giveaway when I hit
18,000 subscribers I will use a random
comment picker to decide the winner and
I'll send that subscriber a copy of a
night of the seven kingdoms by george RR
martin you should also check out all my
other Game of Thrones Season 7 videos
and comment on those for a better chance
at winning I'll link my season 7
playlist right at the top here and I
just added a war for the dawn video
yesterday and one about your own
Greyjoy's history the day before that so
be sure to check those out thanks for
watching I'll talk to you soon